hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember Christmas Christmas Christmas
Christmas Christmas Christmas Christmas
I love Christmas treason of joy best
time of the year if I put somehow make
love to Christmas I would and then I
would eat to consume all its wholesome
holiday juices I love it that much I
love the snow
I love the presents I love the
decorations I even love these obnoxious
little novelty items that burn money
like a Yuletide fire but most of all I
love but most of all I love the
Christmas specials the movies the shows
the classic shorts I love them all but
which ones are the best I mean I know we
all had to watch the rankin/bass stuff
because we mentally enslaved ourselves
to do so but which specials hold up the
best which ones capture the true essence
of Christmas which ones are the funniest
saddest or most influential well tonight
seeing house the 12 days of Christmas
I'm counting down the top 12 Christmas
specials of all time why top 12 because
it's Christmas this is the top 12
greatest Christmas specials
number 12 Merry Christmas mr. bee living
mostly in the world of silence mr. beam
shows us that you don't need dialogue to
be funny or Christmas Abbey the
character is kind of like a
nine-year-old trapped on man body so
like a child he encompasses all the
excitement about Christmas but not much
of the heart he's selfish but he's also
innocent just like most of the kids at
Christmas time a good example is where
he's playing with the nativity scene
like a GI Joe playset he's not being me
he just doesn't know anybody I just
pretend that the baby Jesus was a
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle i Iowa's
grounded for a week there's also a great
scene where he writes out a ton of
Christmas cards and then sends them to
himself
that's what funny and kind of sad at the
same time most people remember to give
him this turkey on the head see which
results in one of the funniest lines in
the show we got the turkey on there's
also a great joke about getting his
girlfriend a ring but I won't dare ruin
it for you here by the line mr. bean was
full of surprises and almost entirely
visual humor which just goes to prove
that Christmas doesn't always have to be
heard to be fun
Merry Christmas
number one South Park a woodland
critters Christmas South Park has done a
lot of crazy especially mostly with that
little piece of crap this range but the
woodland crews Christmas was by far the
funniest because it makes everything
that Christmas was with everything that
Christmas wasn't it deal with all your
Christmas favorites like the day orgies
sacrifices abortions and that's just a
name a few Merry Christmas
the special centers around Stan as he
keeps performing all these favors from
these weird talking animals called the
runeblade
birdies there was squarely the squirrel
rabbit II the rabbit beaver II the
beaver and Barry the bear woodpecker II
the woodpecker mousie the mouse and
chickadee II the chickadee what the hell
who's even a narrator who tells Stan
what to do in right weather Stan likes
it or not he ran out the living room
turned off the light and went back to
the forest to set everything right
he thought he could hide from his
problems not true he knew in his heart
the thing he had to do yeah you knew
that only by going to the forest God I'm
not showing much because this Christmas
special literally has surprise after
surprise and each one just gets funnier
and funnier especially the reveal about
who the narrator is always shocking
always controversial and always funny as
hell the woodland critters Christmas
special makes us all thankful that no
matter where we spend Christmas at least
we're not spending it and suffer
don't know Berta
Disney's the little match girl I read
I'm kind of cheating on this one as it's
not focused entirely on Christmas but
look there is a Christmas tree in it but
not only they have the importance of
hope dreams and the helping of the knees
certainly shattered through most of you
probably never heard but believe me when
I say it's one of Disney's finest it's a
southern man short that's both sad and
uplifting combining the elements of
charity love and the fragile nature of
human life and I have to admit it's one
of the few things in my life that
actually did manage to give me an
ulterior Oh shop unfortunately the
shortest only featured on the Platinum
DVD edition of The Little Mermaid which
I'm sure doesn't please people like that
nostalgia chicken
I hate this movie I sold my soul forever
China and a man I don't know
Neela's de Seine little MatchGirl really
does need its own DVD movies it's
touching endearing and maybe the
strongest thing Disney has done since
they're not a Maria from Fantasia if you
haven't discovered it yet
do yourself a favor of this Christmas
and definitely check it out
remember home when you get past all the
slapstick and some of the throwaway
jokes hold on is actually a very
likeable Christmas book it's a movie
that didn't have to be very Christmas
centered the director is Columbus
decided to go the extra mile by
surrounding it in reds and greens blank
Christmas songs and creating a very
bratty but also very innocent character
to observe it all this could have just
been another slapstick comedy but they
treated it seriously
giving it a lot of heart and a lot of
soul Macaulay Culkin is often remembered
for being kind of as marketing icon and
his later movies definitely should've
been but look at him here that's
entirely genuine capturing both the
whiny selfish side of being a kid but
also the innocent lovable side as well I
especially love the mother and what all
the psychotic when she goes through just
to get home to her son that says
Christmas the season of Perpetual hope
if it cost me everything I own if I have
to sell my soul to the devil himself I
am going to get home to myself again
that's both funny and touching and I
love how when she does get home Kolka
doesn't forgive her at first he
remembers what she did
he needs an acknowledgment of it sorry
and unfortunately that's all I eat the
family element this movie actually seems
very believable sure they all fight but
in the end there's still a family and
the Christmas spirit always manages to
shine but let's be honest that all comes
from the paint buckets look above all
come along because no one should have to
spend Christmas by themselves
cover your go up 31st this movie really
knows how that was annoying this movie
really knows how to portray Santa Claus
and that he's not just a chubby jolly
guy he's sophisticated and dignified
which only actor Edmund Gawain could
provide it's basically about a man who
really thinks he's Santa Claus and so a
court case is drawn out to prove whether
he is or not cuz that's just what kids
want to watch right a court case
surprisingly though Miracle on 34th
Street is very entertaining for kids a
lot of things not just due to Gwen but
also to a very young Natalie Wood who
seemed smarter beyond your years but
still essentially a little kid he said
what kind of an animal are you and I
said I'm not an animal I'm a girl I'm
like the reaming where the kid just
seems like a walking pudding commercial
I probably won't get another chance to
see you unless I get arrested which is
very unlikely since it's Christmas Eve
and I'm going to bed
uncharacteristically early ok yeah
please it's funny because the
explanation of how Santa gifts released
what the male argument doesn't really
hold up anymore in fact that is one of
the few things the remake change I
actually thought was a good addition but
still the actors really pull this off
making this a very charming and very
elegant Christmas paper amid a class and
taste it's just what Santa ordered in
this enjoyable class under variomatic
Christmas to you Thank You mr. Payne
number said the small one this is
another one I'm sure a lot of you hadn't
heard him but really is timeless it's
about a boy his relationship with his
donkey who he has to sell because he's
getting to only the rest of the story
follows the boy as he tries to find a
suitable buyer but none of them seem to
be kind or generous up for the boy to
give him away I have problems getting
rid of my jackass too but I think this
the ending is pretty easy to figure out
but I won't ruin it for those who had
seen it let's just say it's a perfect
ending to what is ultimately an
enjoyable and charming Christmas wish it
was directed by Don Bluth before he left
the Disney Department and like most
prime Don Bluth material it tugs at your
heartstrings and brings on the status
but like his films as well it ends on
the handout which of course makes
everything ok
I'm emotionally scarred but the ending
is so happy ok it's one of the stronger
pieces and yeah it's only a half hour
walk keeping a short and sweet you can
find it on this Disney holiday DVD at
most DVDs stores and much like the small
one himself it doesn't cost much is
worth every penny
number six
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation
okay your novelty is wearing off true
you're hanging on my thread much like
home alone Christmas vacation ooh how to
combine the annoyances but also the
charm is staying home for Christmas what
I really like about this movies they
have focuses on a lot of details sure it
is all the pratfalls it's slapstick like
many physical comedy but it also has all
the little moments that you don't think
about but always recognize like the
grandparents of sleep on the chair but
so much is mindlessly watching a
Christmas show and especially the family
conversations any time sweet you they
took a pint of floor out of my lower
back you see this man I got him
ha you're not gonna be like what
the bill got all the bits that most
people find annoying but also
surprisingly endearing at Christmastime
Pat and I'm always shocked that even
though Jimmy chase plays such a filthy
dirty evil he still seems to be likeable
in his naivety oh he wants us the
perfect vacation which of course never
happens but by the end he realizes all
the memories that's left behind and how
they'll enjoy them for it funny detailed
and capturing every Christmas moment
Christmas vacation knew how to expose
this holiday from the enjoyable qursaya
and that's I believe in it there but I'm
Adam joke I break it out alright Sheree
you talk one more time I'm gonna put a
bullet in your head and call it macaroni
number five It's a Wonderful Life I'll
be honest when I saw this movie I'm
saying to myself come on Christmas
classic nourish the spirit within me see
what you got oh yeah you got a special
effect that looks like someone spilled
coffee on this movie's got a blog but as
I let the film play on I to succumb to
the movies goodwill and Edison
characters by the time I was halfway
through I was totally hooked the story
about how one man's life can affect so
many people truly is inspiring as well
as hard work though I didn't find it a
little sexist when Jimmy Stewart finds
out what happens to his wife if he
wasn't bored tell me where my wife is
I'm not supposed to Dale leaves Clarence
tell me where she is
you're not gonna like a George where is
she she's an old maid she never married
oh you mean she never got married that's
the only important thing to a woman
isn't it pushy pushy she's just about to
close up the library oh and she's
worried of the library what kind of
horrible way is les full it's false the
movie really knows how to give us what
it promises making us realize what a
good wonderful life we truly do have
especially around Christmas time Jimmy
Stewart as usual is chill really good
and director Frank Capra really knows
how to pour the cheerful shields on so
thick that it's impossible not to enjoy
It's a Wonderful Life still proves to be
a wonderful movie that's right
unemployed time
number How the Grinch Stole Christmas
it's funny how a lot of these Christmas
specials seem to focus on the negative
take the Grinch for example he is
literally stealing Christmas and the
whole special is just showing a great
detail how he's doing it and yet the
Grinch is still very likeable a little
curmudgeon he is with his Grinchy Grinch
brown and the voice of the Frankenstein
monster himself Boris Karloff Christmas
bear around how can you not be drawn to
this holiday stick in the wood of course
all the negativity pays off when we
discover nay he can't steal Christmas no
one can Christmas is something much
deeper than he could ever imagine
as he realizes in the end which is
ironic because the name of the story is
how the Grinch Stole Christmas not does
the grace to Christmas I thought this
was an instructional video there should
be a time machine and a road map of
Bethlehem in this movie and don't even
get me started on a pig ship Ron Howard
if I want to scare my kids with a Green
Monster filled with hot air
I love listen love Al Gore speeches
moment warming still the Grinch was
colorful creative and dripping in
holiday cheer just enough to make
anyone's frown turn upside down maybe
Christmas perhaps means a little bit
more
number three a Charlie Brown Christmas I
can't exactly say why this special works
it just kind of does I think a lot of it
has to deal with the fact that there's
absolutely no budget for this the
animation is simple the actors are kind
of wooden and the story is very basic
but I think that's why it's so good
there's simply no bullshit what you see
is what you get and you knew that even
these people had little money they still
did their best game you know so
straightforward Christmas special and
the effort shows you had great music and
wonderful theme and there's something
about the bluntness of the children
that's actually very refreshing I know
nobody likes me by the way I play at the
holiday she can't remember Friday it's
not like any other Christmas special it
seems to exist in its own strange world
and then for some reason it's kind of
irresistible come on the Charlie Brown's
for the world you're in a family of
brownie it's not laughs I love funny but
I don't think it's supposed to be it's
almost like watching a Christmas pageant
that you do everyone tried their hardest
to create it's not spectacular but you
feel the effort the commitment and above
all this in Syria nothing seems
manipulated at all it's just
straightforward and to the point and
somehow it just works everything I do
turns into a disaster
I guess I really don't know what
Christmas is all about Charlie Brown I
can't really explain it
you can certainly a Christmas Carol
which one any of them there are
literally dozens of versions to choose
from each one carrying the stamp of the
original Charles Dickens classic even
the ones that are lousy still seem to
have some element of good at them simply
because they're using a story that's
timeless thoughtful and unforgettable
the tale of Scrooge is one that we all
know too well not just because of the
story but because we've all met a person
like Scrooge someone who just couldn't
get in the heart of the holidays it's
not until the ghostly apparitions
arrived that Scrooge changes his tone
and sees the value in what Christmas can
and does bring out in all mankind all
the different versions offer many
creative variations the ghosts are
always similar but still vary in design
and tone and even Scrooge and self is
going through a ton of actors and the
come and Beca come on humbug humbug
everybody's taking their shot at the
story even the Muppets but as long as
they have just a scrap of the original
story and will always be something worth
watching about it I think my favorite
Scrooge is either Alastair sim or George
C Scott who both found the subtlety in
the character once housed Scott looks at
his father in the past you can just see
him analyzing man and look at the pure
disgust on students face these are both
great performances never going too far
over the top of all things I actually
like the Disney version a lot too mostly
because they managed to squeeze the
entire story in just a half hour and yet
still managed to get an emotional
response that's hard to do live action
animated or even using puppets but
Christmas Carol is perfect anytime for
any generation to a redeposit
and a Happy New Year to the number one
greatest Christmas special is say with
me now
a Christmas story I know I'm sorry to be
so predictable but this movie just seems
to have it all
Hart innocence and above all why human
it manages to be both broad and detailed
at the same time this film does so well
capturing our childhood that we often
watch it saying Duke how do they know I
do that I thought a way I hid in the
cupboard when I was afraid how do me
ginger spirit this film got everything
about being a self-centered yet also
innocent child the excitement the
emotions to build up even the day drink
I think most kids fantasize something
like this when they were punished by
their parents what did we do
so poisoning I think we all embedded
into our brains never to try this even
though it's a place in the 1950s
everyone seemed to have this childhood
it everyone seems to remember it the
same now many people might think this
film doesn't accurately represent
Christmas it just represents childhood
and how materialistic we used to be but
here's the thing Christmas is also about
memories and the story isn't told from
the point of view of the kid it's told
from the memory of the kid as an adult
which is a huge difference business is
about remembering the good times
comparing how we were then to how we are
now and how we hope to be in the future
that's the reason for the three ghosts
in the Christmas Carol this movie words
to say it captures everything we
remember about Christmas to a tee it
allows us to compare it to who we are
now who we will be in the future on top
of that for me there's one scene that
just sums up Christmas all together all
right
Hey look at this oh is that beautiful ah
and that just about does for me that's
Christmas sitting by the tree just
watching the snow with your lenses most
people miss it but for me that's my
favorite scene this movie is like a
dream in America remembering that
childhood innocence is struggling to
keep it alive even as you grow and as
long as movies like a Christmas Story
around I don't think we'll ever lose
track a Christmas story the best
Christmas special and those are my top
12 greatest Christmas specials of all
time Happy Holidays goodwill toward men
and rest in peace of not just singing
trees instead let's listen to some
rockin Christmas puppies I'm a nostalgic
Oh